forty children and three adults were
taken to the hospital after a chemical
leak at a North Carolina pool
firefighters with hazmat gear were
called to the downtown Durham YMCA
yesterday they discovered toxic fumes
after a sodium hypochlorite leak the
chemical is used to disinfect swimming
pools Omar Villafranca is in durham with
how the emergency escalated Oh mark good
morning
good morning the children injured here
at this YMCA were young between the ages
of 6 and 12 and it all started when a
lifeguard reported a strong chemical
spell coming from inside the indoor pool
pump room around that same time that's
when some of the swimmers started
showing symptoms and saying they didn't
feel well
toxic Oh hazmat situation chlorine
leaking dozens of children were swimming
at the YMCA pool Wednesday when
nine-year-old Kamali Siler says they
were suddenly told to get out of the
water everybody came out coughing
choking spitting up Kamali said she felt
lightheaded and her throat hurt they
said that they I needed to meet them at
the emergency room her father says
Kamali was discharged after being
treated for sinus irritation she was one
of 40 children transported to the
hospital for treatment
some children began complaining about
nausea and breathing issues our camp
staff immediately contacted EMS and
began notifying parents where is the
Echo Lake no hazmat crews entered the
wide to try and figure out the problem
officials say the cause of the leak
appears to be a mechanical issue sodium
hypochlorite mixed with another chemical
giving off noxious fumes where those two
chemicals mix there was a lead
and that got down to the floor and
started reacting we show their manners
not supposed to in April 7 children in
Michigan were found unconscious at a
hotel pool a 13 year old boy died of
carbon monoxide poisoning officials said
the pool heaters faulty exhaust pipe was
likely the cause all the children in
yesterday's incident are expected to be
ok but parents like the mother of
six-year-old Aiden Higgins are still
rattled it's very scary because that's
my only child he won't be eating food
I'm cool with them emergency crews and a
team from the YMCA will inspect the pool
before it's allowed to reopen but
there's no timetable on when that will
happen as for the cause of the leak
that's still under investigation
margaret omar thank you